[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur TV 78
nous sommes le lundi 13 novembre voici
les titres plus de 105000 personnes ont
défilé hier dans les rues de Paris
contre l'antisémitisme en tête de
cortège de ivelinois la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale brun Pivet le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher qui
était à l'origine de ce rassemblement et
d'autres élus du département étaient
également présents interview des jeunes
qui parlent aux jeunes il y a quelques
jours quatre étudiants de BTS de la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet ont
organisé une conférence sur le sujet du
cyberhcèlement dans la salle des lycéens
sensibilisés par une capitaine de la
police nationale en France 20 % des
adolescents ont déjà été victime de
cyber
harcèlement pour la deuxè fois le
vélodrome national de 50 ans accueillit
le Sky paratt un tournoi international
de tennis de table en 10 Sport plus de
260 parapongistes venus de 40 pays se
sont affrontés dans l'air centrale la la
délégation chinoise abriillé la France
termine au pied du podium et puis les
invités du 78 en 2è partie d'émission
zoom sur l'entente le chaîn et
Versailles les deux équipes premières
évoluent en National 2 pour les femmes
et en National 3 chez les hommes au
retour sur le début de saison parlera
également des premiers pas en NBA de
Victor wembanamac qui a débuté le basket
justement à l'ELCV 78 et nos deux
invités seront tout à l'heure Philippe
FAM le président du club ainsi que la
co-capitaine de l'équipe première
féminine et son nom c'est Marie d'or ce
sera tout à l'heure dans le 78 mais avec
moi dès apréssent il a michelel midoro
bonsoironsoir réac très beau programme
sport ce tv68 gros programme sport et
justement avec vous on va parler de
l'actualité sportive dans le département
notamment des résultats on va parler de
quoi on parlera notamment football avec
la VI victoire 6 à0 de Versailles en
National et on aura également dans
quelques instants dé Mo de Louis Burton
le skipper originaire de Rambouillet qui
fait actuellement la Transa JAC VAB il
nous a envoyé une petite vidéo vous
verrez dans un instant c'est exclusif il
a fait cette viddéo juste pour les
téléspectateurs de tv78 ce sera tout à
l'heure dans le 78 mais on va d'ors et
déjà parler des infos du
jour avec Michel abord cet accident
survenu en fin de matinée qui a très
fortement impacté la circulation sur
l'autoroute à 12 un accident
impressionnant c'est produit en fin de
matinée sur l'autoroute à la jonction de
LA1 en direction de la province dans le
virage juste avant la ligne droite qui
longe l'aérodrome de saint-cier l'écol
un poids lourd a perdu le contrôle et
s'est retrouvé en équilibre sur le
parapet l'arrière du véhicule suspendu
au-dessus de la chaussée une voie a été
fermée pendant plusieurs heures pour
permettre l'intervention des secours
créant d'importants bouchons à 17h la
route a fil était rouverte pour le plus
grand bonheur des automobilistes voilà
pour cet accident à la jonction de la 12
avec la 13 petite pensée à notre
collègue Clara de Frutos qui restait
bloqué pendant plusieurs heures dans ce
cet accident alors l'image marquante du
weekend justement Michel on en parlait
dans les titre plus de 100000 personnes
ont défilé ce dimanche à Paris lors de
la marche contre l'antisémitisme en tête
de cortège deux ivelinois il a elbron
Pivet et Gérard archer uni contre
l'antisémitisme la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale Yelle Bron pivé et
le président du Sénat Gérard Larcher ont
mené ce dimanche le cortège de la Marche
pour la République et contre
l'antisémitisme dont ils sont à
l'initiative à leur côté de nombreux
élus ivelinois étaient également
présents notamment la sénatrice Martha
de Sidrac ou encore le député de la 12e
circonscription Carl olive plusieurs
maires du département ont aussi fait le
déplacement parmi eux Pascal tevno le
maire de véisi vill coublé ça me
semblait
important de rappeler à la fois notre
attachement au valeurs de la République
moi j'étais agréable al pas surpris mais
satisfait euh qu' a beaucoup de monde et
surtout que ça soit une marche sereine
digne avec des des champs de la
Marseillaise un respect de chacun
finalement les républicains les Français
les citoyens qui se retrouvaient pour
Vaah dire qu'ils étaient attachés au de
la République et que l'antisémitisme
n'avait pas sa
place l'objectif de cette marche
réaffirmer la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme depuis le début de la
guerre en contre entre Israël et le
Hamas plus de 1200 actes antijuifs ont
été recensés en France la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale yel Bron pivé a
également été victime de ces actes
antisémites toujours dans ce contexte de
guerre entre Israël et le Hamas un appel
à la paix au cesser le feu était
organisé samedi du côté des Mureaux près
de 300 personnes ont manifesté pour la
paix à Gaza ce samedi organ organisé par
le collectif blouse blanche et liberté
fondamentale la manifestation avait pour
but de soutenir les Palestiniens
victimes du conflit mais aussi les
civils juifs et les chrétiens orthodoxes
on veut la paix pour tout le monde on
scander les manifestants à politique et
citoyenne la manifestation n'avait pas
pour but de contrer le rassemblement
contre l'antisémitisme de dimanche à
Paris on reste au Mureau au Mureau tout
autre chose Michel demain le Salon
honomie Habitat ouvre ses portes au
public alors vous connaissiez
certainement le salon honomie mais cette
année c'est là à première édition du
Salon itonomie Habitat le thème du salon
cette année un habitat inclusif pour les
personnes âgées ou porteuses de handicap
l'habitat est aujourd'hui perçu comme un
facteur décisif de la qualité de vie le
salon est organisé par le département
des imines ainsi que le département des
Hautes scèes dans le but de promouvoir
un habitat accessible et adapté à tous
le salon réunira près de 40 exposants
déclinés en quatre univers les
aménagements les services et la vie
sociale les solutions d'habitat service
et les financements pour les intéressés
rendez-vous mardi 14 novembre des 9h à
l'oxygène Factory des Murau et puis à
Chantelou levvg les restos du cœur ont
investi leurs nouveaux locaux l'antenne
locale des Restos du cœur a inauguré ce
nouveau ces nouveaux locaux aménagés par
la ville il se situe rue d'andrésie dans
l'ancien Carrefour Contact après
plusieurs déménagements ces dernières
années l'association a enfin son adresse
définitive et un bâtiment flamban neuf
avec ses nouveaux locaux les
bénéficiaires de l'association et les
bénévoles pourront profiter de
meilleures conditions d'accueil avec un
réfectoire un bureau administratif ainsi
que des l'association est aujourd'hui
présente dans une vingtaine de communes
ivinoises merci Michel et si vous aussi
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
Yvelines n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag set
news il y a quelques jours c'était la
journée nationale de lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire un phénomène qui
prend de plus en plus d'ampleur
notamment avec le poids et des réseaux
sociaux et pour parler du sujet des
jeunes d'un BTS de la ber Bergerie
Nationale à rambouillen ont organisé une
conférence sur cette thématique du
cyberhcèlement qui touche une famille
sur quatre en France dans la salle pour
animer cette conférence face à 155
lycéens la capitaine de police Katia
landet du du commissariat de Rambouillet
le reportage de Julien Lerois nous avons
choisi ce thème car il concerne un grand
nombre d'adolescents dans un monde où la
connectivité est présente des jeunes
pour parler avec des jeunes du cyber
harcèlement dans le cadre de leur projet
d'initiative et de communication ces
quatre étudiants en 2e année de BTS
agricole ont organisé une conférence à
la Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
tabou dépression et suicide une réalité
présentée face à 155 auditeurs
majoritairement lycéens ce jeudi 9
novembre on a décidé parce que enfin il
y a beaucoup d'élèves maintenant qui se
sont harcelés c'estfin souvent le cas et
on s'est dit que l'exposé peut-être ça
aiderait des personn à en parler et euh
en plus on a fait ça le 9 novembre où
c'est le jour contre le l'harcèlement
parce que des fois on a honte on se dit
on abuse un peu ça se trouve c'est pas
de l'harcèlement ù justement on se moque
encore plus parce que on dit qu'on se
faitceler alors que d'autres gens il
pense que non définir ce type de
violence ou savoir comment mieux s'en
protéger pour animer cette rencontre ces
étudiants ont convié la capitaine Katia
landet de la Police Nationale de
Rambouillet des discussions interactives
pour mieux prendre conscience des
répercussions psychologiques la majorité
des cas de cyberhcèlement trouve leur
origine au sein des établissements
scolaires c'est d'ailleurs ce que je
leur explique je leur dis que le
harcèlement a été invent avec l'école
mais que si il prend autant d'ampleur de
nos jours et s'il est aussi grave en
conséquence puisque malheureusement les
cas de suicide sont très nombreux c'est
parce qu'il il se nourrit des des
réseaux sociaux et de l'usage qui peut
être fait des téléphones j'ai appris la
différence entre cyberhcèlement
harcèlement et tout ça j'ai appris les
conséquences qu' peut y avoir et tout ça
non franchement j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
intéressant et c'est quelque chose qui
est quand même assez handicapant et qui
bloque et qui ferme pas mal de portes
donc je pense que oui actuellement c'est
quelque chose qui faut encourager les
jeunes aller voir et discuter pas
forcément force de l'ordre en
premièrement mais déjà discuter auprès
de sa famille auprès de ses amis le
phénomène du cyberarcèlement prend de
plus en plus d'ampleur selon un récent
sondage une famille sur quat aurait déjà
été confronté à ce fléo on parlera de
nouveau de cyber harcèlement demain dans
l'invité du 78 si le monde de
l'aéronautique vous intéresse le groupe
d'ingénierie français segoua technologie
basé notamment à trap organise un grand
job dating il se déroule demain en île
de France plus de 50 postes sont à
pourvoir les explications avec Sonia
fosse qui est directrice adjointre des
ressources humaines interrogé par Régine
[Musique]
ralch ce sont des rencontres informel
sous la forme de portes ouvertes au sein
de nos agences ou alors d'afterwork et
ça permet aux candidats de rencontrer
nos managers nos directeurs et nos
chargés de recrutement c'est l'occasion
pour nous d'expliquer les métiers du
groupe d'expliquer les profils que nous
recherchons et aussi de commencer à
parler de parcours de carrière avec ses
futurs potentiels
collaborateurs nous recherchons 50
profils aéronautiques en Île-de-France
en CDI nous recherchons des profils
d'ouvriers qualifiés et de techniciens
notamment des ajusteurs monteurs des
cableurs des
approvisionneurs nous recherchons aussi
des profils ingénieurs notamment des
chefs de projet ou des ingénieurs
qualités pour accompagner notre
développement
ça se passera donc demain mardi 14
novembre de 17h à 20h au Jungle arch qui
est un bar qui se trouve à Nanterre et
justement on aime cette proximité avec
les candidats et avoir cet échange dans
un lieu externe pour renforcer la
l'échange informel j'encourage donc
toutes celles et ceux qui sont
intéressés au juste curieux par le
secteur aéronautique à nous rejoindre
demain à en savoir plus sur nos métiers
à en savoir plus sur l'évolution de
l'aéronautique et peut-être à envisager
une carrière chez Segula
technologie
l'heure du sport à présent dans le
[Musique]
78 et on débute Michel avec un tournoi
un grand tournoi en disport après avoir
accueilli l'événement pour la première
fois en 2022 le vélodrome national de 50
an nvine a accueilli pendant 4 jours le
Sky para tt French Open un tournoi
international hand dis sport de tennis
de table plus de 200 pongistes étaient
présents pour l'occasion des images de
Julien Lorois le monde du paratennis de
table était à 50 ans en yeline pendant 4
jours le vélodrome national a accueilli
plus de 260 parapongistes venus de 40
pays à l'occasion du Sky paratt ce
rendez-vous était organisé pour la
deuxème fois dans la structure au
programme des centaines de matchs avec
22 classes de handicap 11 pour les
hommes et 11 pour les femmes cette
compétition c'est l'une des plus grosses
compétition de l'année euh c'est aussi
enfin c'est même plus dur que les
championnats du monde de l'année
dernière parce que déjà il y avait pas
les Chinois l'année dernière cette année
ils sont venus à trois par catégorie
minimum mais ça fait du bien de voir un
tel niveau dans une compétition et voir
vraiment ce qu'on vaut sur le plan
sportif ce rendez-vous laabilisé par la
Fédération internationale était
qualificatif pour Paris 2024 ils sont
tous là pour ça en fait hein voilà on a
eu des matchs très tendu puisque c'était
des points à aller chercher c'est les
derniers points de 2023 euh ceux qui
réussissent à gagner des points sur ce
tournoi là peuvent être tranquilles pour
la fin de la qualification par contre
les autres doivent rentrer doivent
continuer à faire des des tournois un
rêve pour beaucoup de sportifs du 78
dans les iines Luc Autier Julien Michot
yrik Adjal espère faire partie de
l'aventure pour les Jeux Olympique on
est tous un peu dans les starting BL
pour les jeux hein donc ici tout le
monde vient pour maximiser les points
connait beaucoup de Français sur la
liste en liste d'attente il y a beaucoup
de concurrents mais on est là on est là
et puis et on verra bien dans quelques
mois mais au final comme je te dis S
impression je fais mon petit bonhomme de
chemin j'avance je me rends compte que
faut y aller step by step au tableau des
médailles la Chine termine première avec
38 médailles dont 15 en or la France est
au pied du podium à la 4e place avec 10
médailles dont de en
or c'est l'occasion de faire monter
l'engouement vers les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques on a vu encore du chemin
pour rejoindre les Chinois qui sont très
forts en paratennis de table B justement
Michel on va continuer de parler des des
Jeux paralympiques et on connaî
d'ailleurs le le parcours de de la
flamme paralympique d'organisation des
gios Paris 2024 l'a annoncé vendredi
dernier deux villes desivines seront sur
le parcours de la flamme paralympique le
27 août il s'agit d'Oudan une ville qui
s'engage pour l'inclusion et montinilo
bretonux avec le vélodrome national de
50 ans livin un site qui va accueillir
les épreuve de paracyclisme sur piste la
flamme partira d'Angleterre Berceo
symbolique du sport paralympique et
passera par plus de 50 villes et sera
porté par 1000 personnes Oudan et
Montini le bretonux doivent désormais
proposer le nom de deux sportifs au
comité d'organisation pour porter cette
flamme leur identité seront dévoilé en
janvier 2024 le football et une victoire
pour le FC versaill versaill a même
largement gagné contre nî sur le score
de 6 à 0 on avait un peu peur de ce
match après le départ précipité de leur
entraîneur Laurent perelade la semaine
dernière et finalement cela ne les a pas
vraiment déstabilisé en supériorité
numérique pendant une grande partie du
match après deux cartons rouges du côté
de nî les joueurs de la cité royale ont
marqué par Meddi balouge Lassana diakabi
jeremen lance Chris Kevin NAD et enfin
Mondi prunier seul bémol de cette soirée
ils ont eux aussi reçu un carton rouge à
la 62e minute de jeu au classement
Versailles est désormais 9e donc le choc
psychologique a fonctionné apparemment
il a l'air d'avoir fonctionné on espère
ça va se poursuivre sur la durée voilà
on continue par du basket dans le
championnat de National 3 le derby qui
est opposé trappe au chaîné Versailles a
tourné à l'avantage des trapppistes il
se sont imposés 88 à 80 sur leur parquet
contre le LCV 78 de son côté châaurois s
incliné 71 à 65 à domicile contre
Saint-Martin les boulognees au
classement Trapp est 8e le chaîné
versaill est 13e et Chatou croissie et
14e et bon dernier et on parle dans un
instant bien sûr du club de l'ELCV 78
nos invités vont nous rejoindre dans un
instant et un mot de hand balle à
présent dans le championnat de
préational plaisir lesclés en difficulté
depuis le début de la saison recevait
courbevie une autre équipe en difficulté
dans ce match sont finalement les
joueurs des hautes scènes qui se sont
imposés sur le score de 32 à 21 face aux
ivelinois le résumé du match des images
de Julien Leroi c'était le match des mal
classés ce dimanche 12 novembre le club
de plaisir les clés derniers du
classement recevait l'avant-dernier
courbeevie un match à enjeu pour la
suite de la saison de préationale en
première période les iblinois ont du mal
dans la construction offensive et
surtout dans l'animation défensive le
score à la posuse 17 à 8 pour les
visiteurs on a été absent sur sur tous
les domaines défensivement et
offensivement euh l'adversaire nous a
posé un problème défensive avec une
défense 15 5 on commence bien le match
après on n pas su répondre tactiquement
offensivement et défensivement à ce que
l'équipe adverse nous proposait donc ça
été compliqué par rapport à ça on s'est
pas adapté au retour des vestiaires
plaisir lesclé tente de revenir au score
mais n'arrivve pas à combler le retard
de la première période pire les joueurs
des hautes scènes continuent d'accentuer
leur avance le score final est sans
appel 32 à 21 face à une équipe qui
était classée juste devant nous je
m'attendais pas non plus à voir ce ce
genre de partie c'est vrai que là il y a
eu vraiment une différence de de niveau
entre courbeevie et nous qui a été assez
impressionnante c'est compliqué un peu
ce début de saison mais voilà on
travaille c'est un peu mieux mais voilà
il y a toujours des choses à changer et
on va pas arrêter de travailler pour
pour remonter et se maintenir c'est le
plus important après ce résultat le club
de plaisir lesclés est bon dernier du
classement avec 5 points de retard sur
l'avant-dernier les joueurs devront
rebondir rapidement dans ce championnat
de préational les ivinois joueront le
samedi 25 novembre à 20h30 à domicile
contre l'équipe de palzo les premiers du
classement un exploit serait le
bienvenu
en bal toujours les féminine de Montini
le bretonux joué également ce weekend
dans le championnat de National 2
Montini le bretonux n'a pas réussi à
s'imposer ce samedi soir sur son terrain
contre tourcoin les inimontaines se sont
inclinés 23 à 17 au classement les
Tinois fondu sur place elles sont à la
8e du championnat après 9 journées on va
prendre le large à présent pour parler
de la Transa jacqu Vabre un ivelinois
est encore en course pour cette course
transatlantique c'est Louis Burton le
skippper originaire de la cellebord à
côté de Rambouillet est actuellement à
la 26e place du classement au dernier
pointage il est au niveau des îles
Canaries avec son coéquipier Davy baudar
il nous a enregistré une vidéo depuis
son bateau bureauvallé regardez salut
les ivelines salut salut bienvenue à B
all voyez des VI à moitié nu parce que
s'est fait passer dessus par une vague
voilà tout va bien on est sorti des
Canar on a on a remonté quelques places
depuis notre palité depuis le départ et
puis maintenant on arrive dans
l'Alisée caractéristi de Lisée il y a du
vent fait beau chaud ça va vite et le
bateau va
vite pon pour le mon l'extérieur on va
aller voir dehors attention desag
en jeu c'est que je me fasse pas tremper
aussi voà donc le bateau
vole quand même pas
mal avec les pointes de
l'ordre 28 29 ne c'est très
rapide j'espère que ça vous plaît nous
on va bientôt voir les premiers poissons
volants aura des images à bientôt il
devrait arriver d'ici une dizaine de
jours en Martinique c'est tout va bien
le meilleur résultat sur cette course
d'ailleurs sur la la course virtuelle
c'est vous en rédaction à qui menez
actuellement les débats Michel puisque
il y a appation je ne me prononce pas
trop trop vite pour l'instant voilà je
je suis dans le ple oui une petite
application qui permet de de retracer
cette course virtuellement merci en tout
cas pour toutes ces informations et
juste avant de passer aux invités du 78
on va jeter un coup d'œil au Pr vision
météo de
demain et des températures qui seront
encore 12 pour un mois de novembre
demain mardi dans les ivelines compé
13°gr à Mantel jolie 12 à Versailles
11°gr à Oudan et Rambouillet le ciel
sera nuageux l'après-midi il pleuvera
dans le car sud-est des ivelines il fera
12°gr à Rambouillet 13 dans les secteurs
de versaill et Oudan et 14°gr dans le
nord du département autour de mante
laajolier ce mardi 14 novembre nous
fêterons les sidouanes tout de suite les
invités du
[Musique]
78 et on va parler basket avec nos deux
invités qui nous ont rejoint tous deux
du club de l'Entente le chaîné
Versailles bonsoir Philippe femme
bonsoir président du club et vous êtes
accompagné de Marie dors bonsoir et vous
êtesvous cocapitaine de l'équipe
première féminine de l'Entente le chaîn
et Versailles on va avoir l'occasion de
parler de la saison des féminines la
saison aussi de l'équipe masculine on
aura l'occasion d'en dire un mot et
pourquoi pas aussi parler de Victor
wembanama puisqu'il a il a démarré sa
carrière du côté de de votre club on va
commencer justement avec l'équipe
féminine pour voir peut-être le
classement s'affiché de cette poule D de
National 2 féminine après 8 journées
l'équipe donc de l'Entente le chîn
versaill compte six victoires pour deux
défaites vous êtes actuel 2e de votre
pool et le dernier résultat on le
précise c'est c'était ce weekend une
victoire 63 6356 contre Neuville en
Ferin bah déjà peut-être un retour sur
ce match comment s'est passé justement
cette cette rencontre alors bah déjà
c'était une rencontre très importante
pour nous parce que bah on joue on joue
le maintien cette année et c'est une
équipe qui était qui fallait battre à
domicile c'était un match assez
compliqué qui était assez serré mais on
a su maintenir le cap on a eu une force
mentale qui nous a permis de de porter
ce match ce weekend vous avez pu
assister à la rencontre fil femme non je
l'ai je l'ai j'ai écouté j'ai suivi un
live mais je n'étais pas sur place
néanmoins comme Marie le dit c'est vrai
qu'il y a une force mentale une cohésion
d'équipe importante qui fait que en fin
de match la différence se fait qu'est-ce
qui a fonctionné qu'est-ce qui au
contraire est encore à améliorer selon
vous
euh selon moi ce qui a fonctionné c'est
notre défense on a une équipe assez
homogène et donc on est assez agressive
en défense ce qui nous permet d'avoir
ces victoires et ce qui a progressé ça
va être notre régularité en attaque et
du coup bah pour être plus régulière et
et on Marquit plus de paniers début de
saison réussi Philippe FME si on fait le
le bilan alors on est qu'à 8 journées
mais je disais six victoires de défaites
une deuxième place pour le moment dans
cette pooule de National 2 oui
absolument c'est c'est un magnifique
résultat compenu que il faut savoir qu'à
l'intersaison nous avons perdu des
joueuxes cadres une très importante qui
qui a arrêté sa carrière euh et en plus
c'était une intérieure donc forcément
c'est c'est compliqué à remplacer et
puis deux autres qui nous ont quitté
provisoirement pour je dirait travailler
pour la nation et pour nos retraites
également donc en réalité on leur
souhaite beaucoup de de bonheur et de
plaisir dans le cadre de leur future
maternité mais c'est vrai que du coup
cette année comme a dit marie est une
année de transition car on ne peut pas
je dir remplacer des joueux cadres comme
ça instantanément d'une d'une saison sur
l'autre donc en réalité l'objectif c'est
de de se maintenir alors pour le moment
on on est dans les play-offs mais le
championnat est long notre objectif
n'est pas de d'être dans les play-off
parce que on a pas la capacité je dirais
en terme d'effectif d'y aller parce que
la saison est déjà longue et les
play-offs il suffit d'une blessée il
suffit d'une indisponibilité pour que je
dirais malheureusement les résultats
sonen trouvent totalement altérés donc
en réalité notre objectif c'est de bien
figurer honorablement de gagner chaque
fois que nous pourrons gagner mais on on
ne doute pas que ça va être difficile en
fin de saison parce que par manque de
carburant comme on dit il y a un risque
effectivement que la fin de saison soit
plus difficile Michel mais quand on
regarde le classement finalement vous
êtes 2e ça se passe plutôt bien est-ce
que vous relevez pas quand même les
objectifs par rapport à à la
saison en fait sportivement moi en tant
que président je dis toujours au aux
filles d'assurer le maintien d'assurer
le maintien maintenant
si on va jusqu'au bout et ben on ira
jusqu'au bout parce qu'encore une fois
avant tout ce sont des compétitrices et
puis moi j'ai j'ai joué aussi à Ha
niveau
il y a pas de raison que je ce soit
différent pour aant ça ne serait pas
très raisonnable cont tenu effectivement
du manque d'effectif que nous avons
cette année et surtout que les play-offs
derrière je dirais c'est à la fin d'une
saison qui est déjà très longue avec un
risque band de blessure par exemple là
si nous avions des une blessure parmi
les joueuses cadres actuels ça ça
pourrait éventuellement changer
totalement la physionomie du championnat
pour nous donc je crois qu'il faut être
réaliste et ambitieux mais avec avec
mesure donc pas d'objectif de de
play-off on l'a bien compris alors
comment ça se passe justement la la vie
de groupe on a compris que vous aviez
perdu des des cadres à l'intersaison
comment ça se passe et ben on a récupéré
un groupe plutôt jeune et dynamique on a
tout de suite eu une bonne cohésion et
une bonne entente dans le groupe et
c'est ce qui nous permet d'être à la
deuxème place aussi cette saison à
l'heure actuelle voilà on a on a su
fédérer un nouveau groupe et voilà on
est on est dans la continuité et on
compte voilà reformer un groupe pour les
saisons à à suivre toujours avec le même
coach du toujours avec V Bardic et puis
Julie robig FAM en tant que assistante
et il faut dire que pour nous c'est
l'ensemble de la team qui mérite ce
classement c'estàdire c'est à la fois
les joueuses mais c'est le staff
technique aussi parce que il travaillent
beaucoup avec de la vidéo ils font du
scooting comme vous savez c'està dire
que tout en étant un club amateur à un
niveau amateur en réalité les choses
sont prises très au sérieux et le
travail paye qu'est-ce qui fait que ça
fonctionne avec vin Bardic depuis toutes
ces années alors c'est c'est c'est un si
je me trompes pas il est au club depuis
7 8 ans M plus puis que il a commencé
par entraîner les les garçons et les
coachés et puis ensuite il est venu sur
les féminines et bah c'est c'est c'est
presque une histoire d'amour avec vinco
parce qu'en réalité on sait très bien
que il est très difficile de conserver
un coach de nombreuses années pour des
raisons diverses et varié a toujours des
AAS qui font que malheureusement les
chemins se quittent un jour ou l'autre
et en réalité avec vinco nous avons
trouvé une alchimie commune
euh qui fait que bah il se trouve bien
dans dans ce club il aurait la capacité
de coacher bien plus haut bien plus haut
mais il ne le souhaite pas pour des
raisons familiales personnel il se
trouve bien dans ce club qui est un club
familial même si il dispose d'une
certaine dimension on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure et et du coup
ça le satisfait parce qu'en plus il il
forme des jeunes euh qui qui lui permett
aussi de pouvoir démontrer son savoir et
et de le mettre en application voilà
alors le prochain match pour vous c'est
samedi prochain un déplacement sur le
parquet des Panthères de mulouse basket
Alsace bah comment vous l'abordez ce
déplacement euh bah on l'aborde on part
en déplacement bah on part toujours pour
une victoire on va donner le maximum sur
le terrain et et voilà on y va vraiment
bah pour donner le maximum et et on
verra ce qu'on pourra donner et on
espère la victoire à la clé on souhaite
bonne chance pour cette rencontre
peut-être un mot aussi sur l'équipe
nationale 3 masculine alors qui on est
dans une situation un peu différente que
que les féminines puisque cette équipe
masculine est 13e sur 14 après 9
journées deux victoires pour cette
défaite elle a perdu on disait tout à
l'heure le le derby desésivines on peut
le dire face attrape ce weekend comment
vous analysez le début de saison des de
l'équipe masculine le début de saison
est difficile alors il est vrai que à
l'origine en fin de saison dernière nous
Ress en Prénationale et puis il se
trouve que la fédération française
basket a demandé a dit qu' elle a loué
quelques ce qu'on appelle wildcard
c'està-dire des des montées surdssier et
c'est vrai que comme nous avions terminé
4e de l'île-de-fance qui est une grosse
je dirais région en terme à la fois
quantitatif et qualitatif et puis que le
LCV est un club je dirais référent et
bien notre dossier est passé et donc
nous sommes montés en National 3 on l'a
pris je dirais en en juin juillet alors
que l'équipe avait déjà été consti situé
bon mais pour autant si on regarde les
résultats bien sûr il y a il y a de
nombreuses défaites mais des défaites
pour la plupart sauf une qui où il y a
eu un écueil mais de 2 à à 10 points en
réalité en basket on sait que de à 10
points ce n'est rien du tout c'està-dire
que ça peut basculer d'un côté comme ça
peut basculer d'autres il aurait suffit
qu'on gagne deux matchs de plus et on
était au milieu du tableau et comme ce
championnat est long puisqu'il y a 14
équipe dans dans dans la poule enté on
est qu'à un tiers du championnat donc
rien n'est perdu on a d'ailleurs essayé
de motiver l'équipe en lui faisant
prendre conscience qu'elle avait des
ressources d'ailleurs le match précédent
qui qui qui avant avant trappe était
biorel à domicile qui était auut tableau
et que nous avons que nous avons battu
d'un point non gag nous avons gagné
après un match extrêmement serré et
c'est sur la fin comme un peu au niveau
des des féminine que bah la ressource je
dirais de cohésion s'est trouvée et que
bah nous sommes repassés c'est devant
alors que nous avions mené trois
quartons sur quatre et et et et on voit
que il ne faut pas grand-chose pour
qu'effectivement ça bascule du bon côté
par rapport au mauvais côté donc en
réalité moi en tant que président je
reste confiant la team reste confiante
et puis malgré tout le sport est ainsi
fait que Ben une saison ça peut marcher
puis une autre saison ça peut ne pas
l'être et en réalité c'est la loi du
sport la saison est longue dans dans les
deux sens on parlait de de ça pour les
féminines c'est également le cas pour
l'équipe masculine je vais parler avec
vous aussi de Victor wembanama je pense
que ça vous dit quelque chose mais juste
savoir déjà alors on a parlé déjà avec
vous Philippe FEM de ce petit est devenu
grand puisqu'il a fait ses débuts en NBA
il a fait ses premiers pas en basket du
côté de l' l'entente le chîn versaill
même si par la suite il a été formé du
côté de de
nanter est-ce que vous en parlez de
Victor wembanyama au sein de de
l'effectif est-ce qu'il y a un
engouement dans le club de voir un
Français voilà briller en NBA alors il
brille individuellement un peu moins
collectivement on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en parler bien évidemment
on en parle et on en discute bah voilà
c'est c'est un jeune qui a été formé au
club et et tout le monde le suit et le
soutien au sein du club Philippe oui
effectivement mais comme je vous l'ai
dit il a fait ses premiers pas chez nous
mais en réalité c'est le club de nan il
faut rendre à César ce qui lui
appartient qu' qu'il a vraiment formé
avant qu'il prenne je dirais ses
premiers contrats pro bon Victor moi je
l'appelle Victor parce que je je le
connais
bien et hors norme c'est-à-dire que même
en NBA ils n'ont pas encore mesuré sa
capacité et même le coach coach Popovic
qui est un coach je
diraisque iconique hein je veux dire il
est respecté euh de tout le monde bah il
a même avoué au dernier match cette nuit
que en réalité il n'avait pas encore
trouvé le moyen d'utiliser toutes les
capacités de victeur parce que il c'est
la première fois qu'il y a je dirais un
joueur de ce type alors bon il met quand
même en moyenne 20 points en tant que R
Mo de 19,7 points depuis le début de la
saison on chterà très très précisément
oui une moyenne de 20 points pour un
rooki c'està-dire une première année
alors bon il premier draft quand même
donc il il se doit bon il a fait un
match extraordinaire contre les sons
avec 38 points où là il a vraiment
démontré toutes ses qualités la
problématique qu'il rencontre c'est que
il est dans une équipe formatrice qui a
beaucoup de jeunes où beaucoup de
Français sont passés je rappelle que
Tony Parker il a ses quatre bagues au
Spurs donc en réalité c'est l'intérêt
d'avoir été drafté par par je dirais les
c'est d'ailleurs Popovic le souhaitait
hein il a fait en sorte de de pouvoir
être le premier qui qui choisit mais il
aurait besoin d'avoir avec lui un vrai
mneur qui lui permette effectivement de
pouvoir s'exprimer parce que là il doit
créer victor est un créateur mais un
créateur je dirais sa à sa stature et à
sa hauteur il faut quelqu'un pour l' il
serait dans l'équipe de donkic je vous
dirais que ça serait autre chose oui
juste pour préciser les Spurs compte
après 10 matchs se défaites trois
victoires seulement une 13e place mais
vous le disiez finalement
individuellement quand on regarde bah
c'est le premier roi depuis shquille oil
quand même a cumulé 85 points 35 rebonds
et et 10 contre on a envie de dire début
de saison individuel réussi c'est plus
collectivement ou il est un peu seul
dans dans cet effectif voilà mais en
réalité on le savait je tout le monde le
savait les les speur sont en
reconstruction depuis que ils ont quitté
le le haut du pavé et et et Popovic
travaille avec jeunes mais qui ont
beaucoup de qualité sauf que ce sont des
des des turbos qui jouent plutôt
individuellement que collectivement donc
en réalité Victor lui qui est un crateur
il il est plus passeur d'ailleurs dans
le cadre de ce de cette équipe qu'il
n'est réalisateur même s'il met 20
points en moyenne par match il pourrait
en mettre beaucoup plus si effectivement
il avait plus de de personnes à son
service entre guillemets et en
particulier un vrai menur car il n'y a
pas de vrai meneur au niveau des SPS
mais je pense que ça changera d'ici
quelques temps très rapidement marie
puis qu'il nous reste 30 secondes vous y
croyez à victoram NBA a continuer son
éclosion oui bien évidemment j'y crois
bon on lui souhaite tout le mal qu'on pu
souhaiter on on suit bien sûr Michel sa
carrière avec grandès R est-ce qu'il va
venir vous voir peut-être dans les
prochains mois les prochaines années il
est trop pris il est trop pris hein non
non non non non c'est pas prévu pas pour
l'instant non c'est pas prévu enfin il
est tellement je dirais demandé et puis
en plus il est tellement sollicité par
par tout le monde les médias mais aussi
le Milie le monde sportif non non et
puis je crois qu'il il faut laisser
vivre sa sa vie je dire américaine pour
le moment il a besoin de s'y adapter
parce que il est encore très jeune
d'ailleurs sa sa maman ou son papa
l'accompagne en alternance parce que il
faut pas oublier qu'il a un un frère et
une sœur qui sont en France et qu' faut
bien aussi s'en occuper hein merci
Philppe FEM président de l'entant le
chîn et Versailles merci également à
Marie dor co-capitaine de l'équipe
féminine euh première donc l'équipe
première féminine qui joue donc je le
rappelle son prochain match Sami
prochain déplacement sur le parquet des
Panthères deous on vous souhaite une
bonne suite de saison hein parce que
elle est encore longue en Nationale 2
voilà c'est la fin du 78 merci de votre
fidélité on se retrouve dès demain pour
une nouvelle édition belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78